Kenilworth in Warwickshire a fortress
for King John lancastrians Tudors
Elizabeth the first here you'll find a
giant ruler of royal succession and the
strength of this timeline through our
history has always depended on events
and who wears the crown
these walls may have crumbled but King
Charles inherits a country still
predominantly monarchist however the Sky
News ipsos poll shows support for a
republic is at 25 percent its highest
since the early 90s so what makes a
popular Monarch well I think it's a
number of factors of course but firstly
I'd say a monarch shouldn't really kill
or persecute its subjects that's
obviously a clear thing but also it's
all about Society whether Society did
well at the time was it prosperous was
it politically stable were there Wars I
mean Elizabeth the first for example has
gone down as being called Gloriana and
good Queen Beth and I think that's
because she had such a stable long reign
and in these times of financial
difficulty our polls shows that more
than half of us feel the Royals get too
much public money I respected the kings
of you know
in the past where they'll be out in the
battlefields yeah but
you don't care about it it's a privilege
it's a very privileged accident of birth
thing that costs a fortune to see what
see the lavishness of it and the expense
of it one day I think they represent the
UK all over the world but they do visits
bring everyone together the Commonwealth
are they good value for money
especially a slim down monarchy you know
sort of working Royals focus on that
londoners and the Scottish are least
supportive of the monarchy according to
our poll this was the cue for the book
of congratulations in Glasgow and here
we found little enthusiasm for the big
day especially with the number of people
striking who should be getting a wage
increase and it's totally well it's
never the right time for them to be
doing it but it's it couldn't be worse
I've got people saying oh tourism people
can watch it but when you've got the
rest of the nation like literally
struggling day to day I think it's
absolutely disgusting personally I know
in Scotland there's probably not the
same banners and Street parties but as a
family we're going to celebrate it just
at home quietly watch it on Italian
stuff you have the family around
interestingly over more recent years
Charles has seen his personal
favorability rise from 32 in March 2018
to 52 today whereas his youngest son
Prince Harry who was hugely popular just
five years ago with a 65 rating is now
third most unpopular of the key Royal
just ahead of his wife Megan and prince
Andrew William is the most popular Royal
and William is key to Royal longevity
especially among the 18 to 35 year olds
who are 10 more likely to be Republicans
reflected in the views of these
30-somethings drinking in the Royal pug
in Royal Limington Spa are you
interested in the monarchy no not really
it sounds bad but no I'm not I love the
monarchy however I do feel that King
Charles should have stepped aside and
let will and Kate in They Don't Really
they don't seem to do anything for us I
don't know what I don't know what it is
they do to be honest apart from bringing
money into London there are lessons in
recent and ancient history for now
Britain wants to maintain its monarchy
just a cheaper version